[Music]
i think that sometimes we
and i've heard this on the ramsey show
several times people call in and they
say well this is my situation so should
i either pause the baby steps or leave
this extra money in savings because and
there's only a couple scenarios that you
say to do that so when you're when
you're expecting uh yeah i remember we
talked about this last year in the
pandemic someone had lost their job or
were thinking they were going to lose
their job will you unpack that really
quickly what are the scenarios where we
say let's pause the baby steps stockpile
cash because of this unique circumstance
all other circumstances like for example
150 000 miles on your car i'm like oh in
my mind because i'm like old school it's
only half worn
you could have a out years in that car
you're good put some new tires on it get
some of that fresher smell stuff and
right down there at walmart all three
you'll be good i'm telling you my 1996
jeep grand cherokee that thing smelled
like a go-cart it smelled like a goat
because you had actual goats in it
christy that's a fact and that's
actually a fact that's gross
[Laughter]
the goat mobile i don't know we're the
goat lady i never knew that i did not
have a trailer no but you were the goat
lady i have a number one best-selling
author formerly known as the goat lady i
mean i feel like that's my next stage of
my brand like
we may have a break marketing
breakthrough right here on the air
there's there's so many people that know
those old farm stories and they're like
oh the fainting ghost tell the fainting
in which like 150 000 miles is not one
of them let's talk about the scenarios
that where you would say yes let's stop
paul cash in this scenario
facts
are what we deal with not feelings
the feeling is
in her case and she was being very
logical about it sure she did a really
good job
her critical thinking skills were right
there yes but what this is is the
feeling is this car is going to go out
at any moment the insecurity of driving
an older car with three little kids
that's right that's a feeling it rises
up it rises up and it grabs you by the
throat it doesn't it doesn't come from
the head down it comes from the stomach
up yeah you know what i'm saying
and
when that makes your financial decisions
you're gonna be broke your whole life
a fact is
the car is in the driveway with smoke
coming out from under the hood it's done
that's a different fact right then i'm
afraid
that it's gonna lay down and it probably
will lay down at some time in the future
and we'll just have to put a bullet in
it
and so um
the uh
so what you've got to do is go okay and
the facts are when we laid the math out
we're not suggesting you drive this
hundred fifty thousand mile car for
eight years
we're suggesting it for eight months
because in eight months you can with
your new found tools in financial peace
university you can accomplish a ton of
goals and get some space behind you now
the fact is
that if you have a baby on the way and
you push pause on your total money
makeover
baby steps and your financial peace that
snowball and you quit paying extra on
the debt and you pile up cash until baby
comes and mommy comes home from the
hospital with baby everybody's in good
shape no troubles then we take all that
cash except a thousand dollars and we
restart all you lost was the interest on
that amount of money
now i might lose my job in the future is
everyone
yeah
everyone might lose their job in the
future not me i work for the government
you might lose your job in the future
i'm just saying you could lose your job
in the future that is a a universal
worry
now that is not a fact that's a feeling
it is a fact but it's a the probability
of
they just announced
that we're all going to be laid off in
four weeks that's a fact right you stop
everything and you get ready but i'm
kind of worried about this because of
the pandemic and people around and i
just generally worry about a lot of
stuff and no that's not a fact that's a
feeling you don't stop on that you plow
through so facts and feelings facts and
feelings help you decide whether to stop
or not